I just heard uh gunshots and thought it
was the labs across the road with their
bikes I went upstairs and I looked out
the window and the armed police were
coming up the road and it was literally
almost instantaneously they got here
within minutes quite scary really
this is the first time dawn has felt
ready to speak about what happened just
outside her door we couldn't come out of
our houses unless we asked and we had to
be escorted down the road
one year ago 22 year old Jake Davidson
ended his Killing Spree turning the gun
on himself just a few meters from her
home as someone who's lived in kiem for
45 years she's seen her community rally
we had people knocking on our door
asking if we needed help we've had a lot
of support
five people were killed by Davison
during the 12-minute attack including
three-year-old Sophie Martin and her
father Lee
there's still plays on me mine because
I'll think of Martial grandchildren and
my great grandchildren that's what I'll
think about
they should remember
what he's done
especially to that little girl
a year on from the shooting there are of
course many who are still processing
just what happened here and as a series
of Ceremonies this weekend there will be
support on offer for those that want it
as well as a private church service
vigils will take place in kiem and
elsewhere in the city organizers say
those impacted can always reach out for
help we are trying to do this as
carefully as possible the city needs to
show its respect and remember what
happened and people that have wanted to
show their respects want and are
welcoming a vigil and some people won't
attend any of it and that's absolutely
fine so we wanted to do just enough
Davison was given back his firearms
license by Devon and Cornwall police
just weeks before the attack the
independent office for police conduct
has completed its investigation into
that decision the findings will be
published after inquests conclude next
year
that aside Friday will be a time for
this community to reflect and remember
those lost
damn why did Sky News in Plymouth